we'll begin your highly-anticipated
regularly scheduled programming in a
minute I wanted to take this opportunity
to bring your attention the importance
of mug Club you've all seen it hand
etched painted girthy asbestos-free but
in light of the four copyright claims on
our Oscars stream and archive that we
received within 24 hours of each other
this week as well as being the subject
of a national news story regarding
Facebook's live video suppression
algorithms I want you to know the Mudd
Club has never been more necessary in
our ability to fight back then today
join up for less than 27 cents a day at
law doors credit calm slash mug Club and
make your voice heard also it is my duty
to inform you that the episode you're
about to see includes graphic half-asian
litigious content not suitable for
younger viewers and or put viewer
discretion is advised
lotter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
with mud club growing into the largest
pay service subscription model on the
internet not only did black o monkey bar
find himself on Big Tex radar but
straighten the crosshairs of the SPLC
see the SPLC are arbiters of what's
determined hate speech and allowed on
the platforms and they decided that
black o had to go
Braco that's what jiske said I should be
expecting you so far I'm more clover nor
less safe LSA is first it's the mug then
it's the bottle nothing safe okay you
want free speech right bugs Gabbar I get
you explain something to you boy free
speech leads to hate speech a speech at
least a bigotry bigotry
at least violence
we don't need your kind of violence in
our platforms deus doctor form us black
Oh black stop with the games YouTube the
SPLC you know we're one of the same my
friend you got to understand that the
First Amendment wasn't made for people
like you it was made for good people
fair people like me
think complicated black Oh free speech
hurts people I never really cared about
hurting people I care about that what
are you wetbacks call it dinero's
you got to make a decision buddy what
you fixing to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's Fogler you want the squeegee I'll
plead you you don't want me to squeeze
your windshield are you sure that's what
that is actually I realize we actually
have my half page and lawyer bill
Richman here so I have to make sure that
our wonderful sponsor at Walters who you
can see that's unloaded it still does
have to be facing you
thank you all they're happy about this
enough practicing firearm safety right
now James O'Keefe on the show today
questions a day before we move on this
is a special episode it's a legal update
episode because oh my god it's been a
week we'll get into all of the false
DMCA's as well oh the Facebook all the
recent D boosting of our videos but my
question to you is which sin do you
think is the most egregious so you tie
in most of the DMCA s on YouTube
Facebook slack of transparency or
professors like Charles Hermes cuz
someone getting sued Larry I'm sure that
we understand full view we bear we are
beyond the point of playing nicely hey
we have Penn Telus comedy here how are
you sir
I'm very good I'm happy to be here
you're aiming to get over 1,000 YouTube
subscribers it's Pantelis comedy right
that's it that would be great and he
writes for the show actually is one of
the few writers we have helpful helps us
behind the scenes at part-time Aziz
brilliant freak from Montreal used to
hate the sound of this kind of accent
now it makes me homesick quarterblack
carrot show me a hood pass what's up
terrible Gerald Morgan Jr how are you
sir I'm doing well sir how are you one
of the day is when today is more like
court of la corte valet it's an XLT
Guzzi pronouncing that correctly Pen
Telus gig you yeah that's close enough
correct his valet and we have my half
asian lawyer bill Richman here people
are really excited for you to be here
hi friends what I always find funny is
that before he's always completely off
to well my professional once we go live
buttoned up right as the show start well
before we move into all of the legal
updates and the legal the potential
legal actions our hash tag Crowder
auntie Oscars party the costume winner
was chase Huckle is that house Browns
chase Huckle I see sharks 13 we have
that over there that image there
he had a [ __ ] Bane costume look at
that look at him big van and then the
the best bill Richmond half-asian wire
builders an art contest winner is
conservative Jedi I think we have that
right here so you guys are going to be
winning a t-shirt indoor mug I don't
know exactly this is a whole different
show today 7+1 by the way to get to
after James O'Keefe 7+1 top big tech
legal
dramas a little bit of a theme here I
feel so bad because Penn Telesis is from
Montreal he calls him by Skype and he
works with the pitch meetings every
morning and then this week because of
all the [ __ ] that's been going on
legally from the Oscars live scene which
we'll get to in a second and say Penn
tellus was here and he had very little
to do because we weren't able to do the
shows
no I don't know what you're talking
about we're in California we'll have you
back out here soon I hope right right
course when you know legal troubles are
done we're going to make a beer a beer
from Brautigan 's beard week might want
to take some yeast from your beard and
do a control sample and see which beard
yields the taste to your beard that's a
good sounds somewhat disgusting no it's
not I've had a beard to be here before
it's delicious yeah what'd ya hear from
some guys beards like oh no no no it was
wrong someone out there can tell me I
think it was rogue brewery but I had I
thought oh this is the last time I sent
my wife on a beer run you'll punch her
in the face a few times so no nose like
this beard beer is delicious really yes
well every time I hear something like
that it makes me think we did a story
about a woman who made it with her no I
was cross with me on the show my legal
representation is present you think this
will bode well for us in a court they're
gonna show a clip from you you sick
bastard it's true it'll show and behind
the scenes all right so listen this is
why bill rice half-asian lawyer bill
Richman is here how are you sir
wonderful glad to be here so let's
explain for people who don't know we
have a few things to get to what
happened on YouTube why you guys have
not seen the Oscars treatment by the way
they're abiding their time hoping that
by the time this last fall strike on
Orosco stream is removed you guys won't
want to see it
make sure when that oscar stream is up
you like it comment us till the cows
come home so they see that you know what
they don't get to play this game but
we'll move on to youtube as well as um
some other issues that are occurring
here behind the scenes and it's just
gotten to the point where our legal
battles of you know the we're at the
point without un retainer you're
probably
coming on the whole time it's really
becoming a full-time job how many
explain for people before we get to
Facebook and James O'Keefe the Oscars
livestream explain to people what
happened there well it's I mean it's a
multiple battle war that we fought over
the last kind of 72 hours this has been
pretty nuts but just on the stream
itself and then the archive there was an
initial takedown I think a lot of folks
a lot of the followers of audience and
fans saw that it got cut down right by
and ABC disney strike copyright strike
they're saying hey you're violating this
and that shut it down right in the
middle and just to focus right on that
the kind of Arc of just the ABC disney
we get the notification the next day we
file a counter notification we work with
some of our channel partners we get in
there start you know talking to youtube
lawyers there were four strikes for
strikes effectively on the same piece of
content yeah right for strikes and the
same piece of content within 24 hours
three of them have been retracted or
struck down whatever term you want to
use three of them especially the one
that happened during the livestream that
caused us to be able to live on YouTube
when we had 40,000 people but this is
important to note well climbing to a
thousand yes this is important to note
and it was a hard strike you get three
of those I think in three months we're
no longer able to broadcast period so
all of the strikes we should mention
this that are hard legal strikes where
when you file a counter notice that's
hey see you in court and they're legally
liable if it's a fall strike they're all
gone yeah so there so we get this one
the first one of the four ABC disney
comes in everything just blows up on
Sunday night then on Monday we're
following the things that we need to do
everyone's getting crazy going you know
trying to investigate what does ABC
disney doing reaching out to youtube
come Tuesday they've dropped it they've
withdrawn it they've looked at all of
our arguments and they've said oops
we're done right they drop it well
that's just the first of the other of
the four so right within the stream
itself after the ABC disney one comes
off on Tuesday the Academy Awards
decides that they want to have exactly I
don't know that they're not run by the
same parent company I'm not entirely
sure the Academy is come on either way
you can't sit it's like they're in
cahoots good I mean yeah it's not look
they're obviously financially it
it's not even to be critical but they
have a network the network's doing an
event and they're streaming the event
and the event is the Academy Awards
right so now the Academy comes in after
ABC Disney has given up and says oh no
no we're gonna keep you down on the mat
but within 24 hours again we unleash the
whole thing again and they file a
response back to our response or reply
if you will that says no no no no no no
no we're totally right four minutes
later I really no no 48 seconds later 48
seconds later the claim is dropped the
claim is off the screen that's not oh
that's just - there's just - let me
interject real quick yeah people
understand this is a tactic that they
use so this is great that we're able to
get these strikes removed right yeah you
can't go back
all but one right you can't go back we
can't go back to Sunday night and get
that live street on strike we watch on
the show that's what so that's a the
strikes and then I want to get into that
any questions numbers strike two
and then we up reupload at the archive
right because the stream was cut at an
hour so what we're gonna reload the
three hours everyone kept working
everyone can you know putting their
contributions together one year by the
way works tirelessly all night because
exporting a for our HD file re x-men
took all night they were supposed to
have a day off no one's had time off I'm
incredibly appreciative to everyone you
know even Brendon continued number three
yeah I mean they they're coming now
after the archive right they've said
okay well we were able to cut you off at
an hour hour and a half on a stream but
now you've got the full thing you're
uploading it so that the people can
actually see what happened and they
throw the same ones in again so we've
got this Academy coming in ABC disney
though appeared to have learned their
lesson and they did not hold attack on
the archive so but Academy goes in they
do theirs now they've dropped theirs
again and then we had a fourth one on
this on the archive which is still there
and we're still fighting right clear
though the fourth one and this is why
this is so important for gonna
understand there's a broken youtube
system right there's if you file a hard
strike and for people out there I know a
lot of people are looking for legal
representation and we're planning on
trying to provide some more assistance
to other people out there at some point
we're just not there yet join up at my
club will have more infrastructure but
the hard strikes that's what's that's
different from a copyright claim that D
monetizes you almost all of our stuff is
D monetize we do a parody
they do you monetize to say you used the
rocket wreck site but we did a direct
parody of rocky we know it's fair use on
that point by the way transformative do
you have the numbers from the Oscars
ánotá was the actual numbers it was said
it was a three a something our stream
yes it was two minutes I believe it was
two hours and 34 minutes of our content
matches meaning non Oscars at all 31
minutes of commentary just talking about
it what is visual visual and audio
overlays that transform the original
work yes into something that is a new
work and is critical of the original yes
okay
I had to fit into a 403 slash Eddie
Murphy raw leather jacket that's trans
guess everything about it was
transformative that trophy I know was
formed Kent
yes it wasn't nearly as four minutes of
total time of the Oscars being full
screen on our screen right four minutes
four minutes and that means with no
commentary at all no with comment was
still both commented how many minutes of
just the Oscars out commentary you could
count it in seconds oh yeah so would
that qualify as transformative because
again you just can't rip people's
content but the law is it has to be
transformative would that constitute
transforming I mean well it's not only
transformed it but one of the other
factors is how much of the original work
are you just showing wholesale and
that's what you're doing is you're
coming in you're commenting you're
adding visuals you're adding you're
actually specifically critiquing the
work or so of the few minutes or really
actually seconds when you break it down
a few seconds of clips here a few
seconds of clips there where you're
literally taking a breath between common
right right yeah I mean that's what that
adds up to over you know almost the most
amount of time we watched was rummy
Malick speech because we said oh he
seems like a real clever you watching it
of course got shut down I all know go
show that I'm known told ABC about it
you know yeah I got a question it's for
you a half-asian lawyer bill Richman yes
sir
if they're repeatedly proven to be false
claims right is there a legal recourse
for us to be like hey listen man this is
3/4 times obviously it's on purpose so
there is there are there is a whole
procedure involved with doing that and
one of the things is is that we can get
involved with
about that so we can get involved with
going after some of these you know
random accounts that are doing small
fake claims and maybe they do one a
month or two or three a month and look
we've got a lot of things that are
happening we can take away from dealing
with this or we can go back in the war
room and start dealing with these but
when they get to a level like this when
you have major companies that are coming
in and saying hey we really don't like
you creating new content and
transforming our works in a way that
appeals to this audience that's when we
have to stand up and do something
different and here I you know it's it's
it's an indictment of what they are
doing themselves that these claims get
dropped so quick well you think they
know all of the claims are bogus right
this is what's important people who are
out there this isn't just about us we'll
get to Facebook in a second we just
happen to be an example unfortunately
because particularly on YouTube were the
number one conservative channel so we
kind of are the blueprint but tomorrow
it could be you one of you could be the
blueprint once you get popular enough
they will come for you and they're
coming for all of us that's what's
important is why we have we have this
atlatl credit shop the deep platform
this your mug club and our sponsors like
Walter keep us in the game we've been
demonetised
yeah on a lot of content a ton of
commits not small money but no and it's
not small money increasing that being
said that's yeah and that's really easy
to do because I can say oh we're gonna
claim this one Clint there really aren't
that there's no recourse now when they
try to hard strike your channel that's
where they affect someone has manually
submitted a legal notice and we built
half-asian bill efficient level watchman
manually submits account is it
accountant onus what is an hour
notification ok counter notification and
at that point it goes to the courts in
other words at that points okay listen
if you are lying here now we're getting
into legal hot water they said okay we
don't want any part of this we've never
lost
they've always retracted those the thing
is it's the same claim on the retracted
the hard legal strike right on the
stream it's the same claim on the
archive oh it's just there's no recourse
because it blocks it in all countries
they're saying we're not heart strike in
your channel we're just blocking it in
all countries so no one can see it and
what do they have they have a month to
respond heart strikes they've got a
month to respond and then you know
there's a different process related to
it but ultimately that is why it's a
it's a criticism of YouTube's system
because when you think about it like all
the history of what we have done over
the last year 18 months two years has
been time and time and time again
demonstrating how these claims are bogus
they're just used to disrupt business
they're used to right maybe people have
to stay like for you
the show to have to pay more people than
do more resources and redo work and
ultimately disrupt the audience and even
though they know it's not ultimately
going to stop us mhmmm they know it is
gonna have a disruptive effect and it's
the only thing they can do so they keep
doing it but how do they keep doing it
youtube allows it to happen so it's not
a system where despite ten twenty thirty
a hundred false claims that we've won
every time and so they have to you know
affirmatively prove it before we get
affected right it's still we get
affected and then we have to come and
prove it the other way right exactly
after after the stream is over four days
after this you know after the event has
occurred and this is pretty consistent
across the board by the way
disproportionately with conservative
channels you know we went out there when
that lady came up was Tom at her was a
Nakul knew she came out yeah and we said
have you been affected at all by the ED
pocalypse she's like no not at all and I
have someone I contacted YouTube look
could we have a name it's a time
sensitive thing right so the Oscars they
happen people kind of move on from it
obviously the shows fun and entertaining
you can go back to it think about it
this way think about if we're talking
about a presidential election or a
Senate election or some bill that's
trying to be passed in Congress and
they're like we're commenting on what
they're doing talking about it or if
Congress is putting something out for us
we're commenting on that they can shut
us down so that we can talents be they
tried to shut us down once with a
presidential debate yeah exactly I was
thinking horrible this is some tool
that's disproportionately used by the
left it's what people need to understand
because conservatives don't go out and
try and abuse the system you can find
more content than you could wash in a
lifetime everything from calling me gay
to a secret transvestite to a part of
the Illuminati to a Nazi secret we don't
go and some have enough female actresses
but we don't try and shut those down you
don't try and shut any of those down we
actively as matter of fact one time
someone ripped an entire show
oh and we just reached out in hey listen
man I I appreciate the the zeal but
could you take it down because it's our
whole show yeah and we'd rather you just
maybe take a clip and direct them to our
show this person put up a clip instead
and directed them to our whole show
perfect we go out of our way to make
sure that we are following the kind of
fair use rules that we preach just gonna
tell you something here we're not
talking about information we're not
someone that a request from somebody
getting sued
that's what we got half-asian alert Bill
Gross be here is there anything that you
think I've missed on YouTube because now
this moves us on to the big thing that
many of you may not know about this week
if you haven't been following James
O'Keefe is the Facebook issue so all
week picture this if this were your job
okay and you suck at math which okay I
do as well
and someone said you have to do math all
day that's your job
that's been my job this week going back
and forth with a bill on legal issues
going what can we do what I'm not good
at this I want to focus on creating
content I want to focus on creating more
shows in this week we were precluded
from doing any of that and poor pend
Ellis was here he just wanted to have a
good time just wanted to tell the jokes
as they say in much of the Greek sound
and instead he said you're going what's
happening with your lawyer okay so we at
YouTube and then we have Facebook well
let me give you a little bit of history
here with with Facebook I guess bill why
don't you jump in kind of on the general
history with Facebook before we're gonna
have James I'll keep on to talk about
the most recent I don't know if this
point is it even a sin at this point
what do you call it you just call I mean
it's just it's just a dishonesty it's
just I don't know go ahead so so
immediately after we met in the
half-asian zone yeah we dealt with your
Facebook debacle and a lot of folks were
around then a lot of the early longtime
fans knew that you know there was a you
know there was a suspicion that things
were not going right and at the time
before the Gizmodo article came out
you were sitting milieu that time we did
not even know each other and at that
point you you finally realized okay
after months and months of trying to
figure out why is my whole advertising
platform being threatened
through Facebook why why is all of this
negativity happening why am I literally
sending them hard checks this is this is
important for people to note with
Facebook I've run ads on Facebook for
years and what happened was all of a
sudden they came to me and said hey you
didn't you're you didn't pay your tab I
suppose on a second you've charged me
for two years every single week and
you've charged me every single week
thereafter there's just a two-week gap I
don't know what you guys did but here's
my credit card here's my paypal fix it
they said we can't you're not you're not
good on your tab I spent one second well
here's another credit card I don't know
it's gonna have to talk with accounts
and I said okay Horan let me talk with
accounts but you're still char
me for ads they would not answer the
calls so you're gonna we're gonna put
your account into delinquency that means
creditors go after me can destroy your
life yeah what did I do your good friend
Jordan said mail them a check physically
to accounts payable they deposit it in I
think we have it as an overlay here and
then they still set up your account
isn't in good standing I'm like we'll
have a second you've taken the money and
you're still taking money for ads what
do I do
and then the Gizmodo article comes out
this was in 2016 I was named as someone
Alex Jones on your faces but what was I
saying I was saying okay so this
happened what's the Facebook is and then
Gizmodo there was an article leaked
where we were manually selected as a
page to throttle it was Ted Cruz Chris
Kyle foundation knife and myself and I
called Bill not knowing what the time
saying I don't I can I don't know if
this is related to the accounting issue
but it can you tell me what you think
and he says let me check it out not clay
Beckman you call me back and you said
yeah this looks really bad well you know
I mean you get a call and you hear
something like this and you think summer
you know you know credibility and some
don't and so you got to check him out
and when we started to look into it and
we started to investigate and we started
to say if you if you investigate it as a
true thing what are the things you could
use to verify that this is the way that
it's happening and when you looked at I
mean before I even got involved you were
time after time after got a message
message message message
money money money card card card check
no yeah
and then Gizmodo just confirmed that
it's the suspicions that you had at the
time that there was something happening
and what the big part here is that that
we've always said this right you know
we've people use the term censorship
which we and we understand it's a
governmental thing versus a private
company thing right anyway this is their
sandbox they can create certain rules
within the Constitution federal law
state law they could have set the rules
or their their sandbox and say I'll do
you can't invite you in you can spend
some money here it'll all be good but
the problem is when they say the rules
are a but they are actually enforcing a
set of rules called B and that's what
happened here they're telling you spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars of your
money to build your business on this
platform because here are the rules but
in reality the rules were different for
you right and breitbart and Chris a lot
of conservatives out there so we've seen
this disproportionately target concerns
we will talk with James O'Keefe about
this this isn't just about us it's about
anyone out there if you've had
suspicions unfortunately we have the
resources to have confirmed quite a few
of these suspicions it's happening I
don't want to say across the board but
it's certainly happening a lot to
conservatives and a lot of people out so
they said well I don't know and there's
no way to prove it well you do have to
take legal action and we've done that in
the past but I think it has to get a lot
more severe going forward imagine it
this is your work you I don't know you
own a factory where you make chairs okay
and you agree to at least you build up a
factor and they come in you have a
five-year lease at year two they say by
the way we're gonna quadruple the lease
what you're paying you so well on a
second we have an agreement like a man
there's a loophole in there but I I paid
for this we had an agreement that's
what's happened with Facebook that's
what's happened with YouTube is we've
come to an agreement largely because
they've courted us they've wined and
dined Dustin sent us sent us to New York
not just largely I mean the Facebook
emails I mean they're basically getting
on their knees like these comes made
your money all right we actually are
taking your money but we don't know
where the money's going it's just going
into the sucker zone right exactly the
sucker zone where all the conservatives
sit there at that what was that that
summit and you're like oh really I think
you're Ernest Becker please don't harm
me he's like I am a human George Soros
is doing right now
Rhonda Mott was awesome um here's my
question so with that that's how we met
yeah the result there was you spoke with
top would you say top legal brass at
Facebook they had some outside counsel
the outside counsel were very helpful
the inside folks they had to get to the
right folks but ultimately the there was
none of this you know screw you we're
not gonna do what you do what you want
what you're saying is completely you
know bogus it was okay here we're gonna
ply your money here's your money back
here I mean it was it was a resolution
that got us what we needed in a place to
where they had the revolution with a
little more acquiescent than that oh
yeah yeah yeah okay it was resolved
outside of court so we can destroy buddy
listen yeah they weren't like bullsh
they weren't tired they were because
they weren't Penn tellers but be that's
it was a myself in the point was a if
there's a problem going forward we'll be
there to make sure it's okay and look
there's there's got to be a fairness
here to say that you know Facebook's one
of the largest employers in the country
there's a lot of people and there's
maybe at times where you could say hey
someone's acting rogue or maybe there's
an unintentional but you know the
Gizmodo article was most important
because it wasn't just one person saying
hey I looked in the cubicle next door
and this guy is the leading conservative
pages right it was like no no there's a
whole room of people and then actually
papers right it's like wow I
accidentally printed this policy and put
it into place for years part of the
resolution with AJ's book and I think we
can since was will we're gonna make sure
this doesn't happen again right and so
that you know we talking about the word
things did change there was a little bit
Oh a little bit is a little little bit a
little change a little baby steps baby
steps no there really may be steps TMT
sex party in Silicon Valley nice yes all
true in and so you know that we move on
right we move on to get back to the
business of content of red face and this
is not going that yeah we wanted to get
back to the content and this could
happen to any of you you know this we've
tried to focus on Khan we've built up a
mug Club to hedge our bets
after this this is another example would
have Facebook started before we get to
James O'Keefe racing Facebook started
something called show pages and they
reached out to us and I said hey we'd
like you to be a show page which was
shows basically as I understood it
multimedia type pages would be in
someone's feed would be given priority
basically you would automatically appear
at the top of the feed I don't know
exactly what it was yeah but lower-level
people reached out and said we think
you're the perfect kind of content for a
show page and we said well hon how is
this going to work once we convert it
what if it doesn't work what if can we
convert back and there's you know what
all right fine we'll give it a go and
they came back to us and uh we came to
here show pic because we were sitting by
and they said I you're not eligible so
here's what's happened it's same thing
that's happened with you two
when they look at just the numbers when
they look at just the impact they go hey
this is the exact kind of content we
want in our platform right very highly
engaged it's content that people are
watching on YouTube for example we keep
people on site you watch an average of
12 minutes per video over 30 minutes on
a podcast we play by every single rule
and they change it so they said please
please please please please turn your
show into a show page we want you to be
one of these pioneers as a multimedia
show pit then you're not allowed to do
it and we always suspected one thing -
we had this we called it here the
YouTube algorithm the YouTube Facebook
sort of equations where if we would have
20 or 30 thousand viewers on YouTube
we'd have a thousand on Facebook
despite at the time we would have more
fans on Facebook we definite about two
and a half million fans something like
that two and two and a half million fans
it would be a tenth to a twentieth to a
40th the number you can compare all of
the use of views to fake we always
suspected we're going on a second our
video that's our bread and butter but no
one sees them on Facebook and we have
screen shot after screen shot after
screen shot of people sending us think
we're not seeing your stuff in our feed
and that again comes well we'll never
let this happen again crowd oh we
promise and remorse if you think this is
happening again now remember one of the
possible explanations here is that they
have the crappiest live stream product
could be well it just waits because our
product is thor's arguments literally
they could come down and say I'm so
sorry it's our fault we cannot do this
because we are the worst
I heard that WWE live streams on
Facebook are super huge they're like
50,000 viewers at any given time and
they run fine so McMahon that's it I
heard a lot of that stuff might be
scripted though
and then so explain that brings us to
we'll have him on in a second that
brings us to what was just revealed in
the O'Keefe video so yeah do you want to
tell people before we bring James out
sure so so most recently James O'Keefe
was you know I'm sure everyone's
familiar with some of his prior work in
doing undercover videos and whatnot but
was able to get some
amazing insider information and not just
someone who decided they wanted to give
an anonymous tip but someone who's
willing to put their you know life at
risk their career their professional
life at risk to describe what was going
on behind the scenes regarding D
throttling or throttling the boost is
the program but throttling of live
streams and specifically again steven
crowder puts in 40 years i'm this page
and the only reason why i don't want to
do i want to talk about myself in the
environment oh I just know what I'm
saying we are unfortunately an example
of potentially anybody but we are the
only as far as I know what page that was
fingered in both the Gizmodo article
back then and now with video live seaman
big part of that was we lost so much
profit on Facebook because people
weren't clicking the links anymore
traffic was being throttled okay we're
gonna focus more on multimedia and then
that one EPS what's going on here
doesn't make any sense we can look at
our growth on mug Club we can look at
our growth on YouTube why that's not
applying on Facebook no answer no answer
no answer no answer
that's what's so important to note here
is this is something we had long
suspected we've talked we matter of fact
we talked about never live-streaming
again yeah on Facebook and just live
streaming because we can only split it
two ways to youtube and to mug club
because we got so few viewers then this
drops from James O'Keefe and we're
sitting there going okay he has the code
he has the actual code that's baked into
our page I can tell me that that's not a
dishonest business practice wait if you
tell us you can't say the word [ __ ]
all right fine you tell me you're not
gonna verify us an Instagram we old okay
from but you can't fake in code that you
don't tell us about that inhibits our
ability to make a living speaking of
which hit the notification bell if
you're watching on youtube which is
really the only place you're probably
watching but more important join month
latter credit.com slash booklet for 27
cents a day and subscribe on itunes as
well so you'll see the audio version and
as we get completely shadow banned or d
platformed at least we can tell you on
the itunes i think let's let's get them
on do we have james yeah what do you
have we okay we have a him here bill I
know you'd like to it's not
cross-examining because he's not that
we're not in court here but James
O'Keefe project very task calm slash
brave I know they're asking people out
there everyone out there to carry
cameras with you and really if you don't
have the hidden camera stuff you can use
your phone we've used that in the past
we just use an iPhone
I'm on the phone no I'm catching you in
a felony James O'Keefe how are you sir
good to be with you sorry to hear about
the D boosting but I'm here to help you
answer with information well I
appreciate it I know you let me know
about this you sent me the video and I
saw the response here from the verge and
then I know Bill has some questions or
Phil do you want to lead this off as far
as your questions with James
I would I would James thanks for being
available obviously everyone's been
following this very closely and the work
is really appreciated I know across the
community in you know probably my first
question right off the bat I think of
what a lot of people are interested in
knowing is how did you understand the
credibility of the information you were
doing that you were obtaining and what
steps did you take to make sure that it
was verifiably correct well that's a
great question I do we know you're not a
lawyer
well this this took a long time let's
see where do I start
so about a year ago we had this insider
sent us these documents and the this was
a lot of documents and I'm not an
engineer so I don't know exactly what
they mean fast forward a couple months
we get a lot of information we need a
lot of tips at Project Veritas as you
can imagine from a lot of people
claiming to be a lot of things right and
we find out that this person did in fact
work or she claimed to work in content
review intellectual property so we look
at the documents and you know my team
went through all these guy and we see
the word D boost and we go whoa because
you don't have to be an engineer when
you see this term and I have it in front
of me I action D boost live distribution
and there was a screenshot of Mike's
Serna [ __ ] this woman had actually
taken out a camera and took a picture of
the computer screen showing this D boo
so well oh my god I can't believe we
didn't notice this earlier answer your
question I could tell the whole story
but I'll cut it - the bottom line is we
I have another sources inside Facebook
that are not willing to go on the record
of course and I and and and a couple of
them logged into the backend and showed
me this engineers named Danny Ben David
showed me his definition of D boosting
so I know this is real I know that it's
not just a made-up document someone
Photoshop because I saw it with my own
from another source that corroborate the
identity of the engineer and the
document itself but the other source was
did not have access to the the other
part of Facebook where this D boosting
activity took place he could only
corroborate that D boosting was a thing
and that Danny ben-david is in fact
someone who works for Facebook and
number three Facebook's response
corroborates the fact that this woman is
real because they fired her and they can
and I'm actually quite captivated by the
response because they say it fired her
for in fact leaking these documents hmm
that's a big deal notice no demential
because I do not know why they fire her
we couldn't report how they fired her we
thought maybe she got fired because she
was a bad input no they fired her for
leaking these documents would this meet
this standard for evidence - does does
his case hold water so in terms of
having some substantial evidence having
someone who can corroborate what the
evidence is that is actually what it
purports to be and they can actually
explain it you're gonna hit those
authenticity you're gonna hit
admissibility so it goes a long way to
what you have and from a practical
standpoint it's not just having one
piece of evidence and that's kind of why
I wanted to ask about the credibility
everything that we do here and I know
that you do as well is based on not just
a rumor or a hearsay or a random
anonymous tip but it's taking those
things and verifying them separately and
individually and so that's knowing what
the credibility is in the steps you took
in addition to afterwards getting you
know essentially verified by Facebook
acknowledging I think Steven you raising
seven plus one by the way that's not
that's not very well researched don't
come out next later later but the other
big point there is that this was the
opportunity for them to deny James the
work that you had done and they didn't
they in fact very much corroborated that
these documents are they they could have
said these documents are fake but before
we do that I do have a question how do
you know I was included on the deepest
amongst the D boosted so and I have a
copy of the you know this is the from
the video this is the actual code it
says I action Sigma I action D Boosh
live distribution this whistleblower
took a screenshot of Mike Serna bitch's
page and then she saw this code appear
on your page Steven we didn't get a
screen
shot of your page but we did get a
screenshot of the code it appeared on
your page this is a cybereye action d
Boosh live distribution by this engine
that's something that was discovered in
a motion for discovery motion for me as
I asked the whistle
I've no whistle or inside or whatever
you want to call her I said would you
swear under oath in a court of law that
you saw this on Stephen Crowder's pages
100% she saw this D boost action taken
on your page and the daily callers page
and my externa bitch's page she did not
see it on any other liberal liberal or
political liberal pages she only saw it
on your page so then I asked you Steve
and I said well did you do anything
malicious did you talk about suicide in
such a way that we get you banned you
really have in the sense that I said
don't do it well that well that's you
shouldn't be well you shouldn't be
banned for that and if you are D boosted
they should be notifying you yes we
certainly were not notified yea of the D
boosting and I think something that's
really important here as well James and
you didn't know this before you release
this article this is how I met bill
Richman we just talked about the Gizmodo
article because they there was a leak
where someone said we were manually
throttling pages before that bill and I
had talked about this
we had several videos trending at the
top of Facebook one was guns and I
Cameron what the other video was it
could have been the feminist Film
Festival and then afterwards we never
trended again and we had an issue with
accounting and that this article came
out and I spoke with with with Bill and
you didn't know that I was one of the
few people named to be to have been
manually throttled before and I think
I'm the only one named in both of these
stories back in that one I was there's
Kyle Foundation Ted Cruz for president I
think Breitbart and yours truly and here
the only three that have heard named are
I believe he said certain [ __ ] Daily
Caller and myself so a big part of us
dealing with Facebook was hey this thing
all happen again
and that's why this story was such a
surprise well when one of the most
shocking things about the story and this
is what the insider said is that what
makes this so damning what makes it so
egregious is that listen let me defend
Facebook for one second here Facebook
has thousands of employees that police
well there are some anomalies where some
crazy low-level employee takes down you
know
ben shapiro it takes down dennis prager
actually saw that happen i the insider
showed me you know some things and I saw
that they but people who get put back up
I mean you can protest you can say
listen I didn't do anything wrong
it's justified with notoriously uh
anti-semitic Jewish scholar Nazi Dennis
Prager yeah we can it's friggin right
but if he's some anomaly some low-level
left-wing employee and Facebook takes
the guy down he gets put back up and
there is a there is a commitment to
police this sort of crazed you know
extremist employees at Facebook because
they're all you know we have sixty
thousand people once in awhile someone's
going to take someone down and there's
there's adults in the room but in this
case the D boosting you guys don't know
that it's happening to you
that's the thing that is very shocking
that is the reason why I asked her she
said well the reason why I chose to lose
my job and leaks these documents she
actually went on food stamps for a few
months because she was broke and
unemployed is because she said the
people don't know that it's occurring it
doesn't even show up on Facebook's
content review I'm sorry on Facebook's
task management system it doesn't show
up that they're doing it it's Shawn I've
got 75 pages of code I action it's
automatic as machine learning they go
through your videos Steven they convert
your videos into text they find key
words the key words trigger an algorithm
which automatically D boosts you and you
don't know that we hadn't we called it
something in the office of the you I
think quarterblack knows us we called a
sort of the Facebook to YouTube ratio in
a sense that we were almost guaranteed
whatever stream viewership we had on
YouTube it would be anywhere from one
tenth to a 30th female on Facebook and
same thing for videos that were uploaded
here's the thing with YouTube and I'm
not I'm not letting YouTube off the hook
here certainly on we just talked about
ABC disney in the broken system there we
can see how long people are watching our
videos for where they're coming in we
can look at demographics we can tell
exactly how many people are watching and
we can never really tell that with
Facebook we haven't be able to monetize
videos as far as I know on Facebook but
when you have consistently videos I
think our average viewership is close to
the million mark and then on Facebook
it's 40,000 50,000 when there's still a
couple million fans who've liked that
age proactively we just had we just
assumed it was well Facebook's dying off
because nobody likes that anymore on
there you know
snappin Wiener pics on snapchat and
Instagram turns out that might not be
the case just some other important uh
well what are the other questions is is
in a lot of these instances when you
hear from one of the social media
platforms they'll say you broke this
rule however subjective or vague the
rule might be and so we're gonna have
this consequence but at least we have a
rule that we can argue with or find
whether that kind of thing
here the response from Facebook is very
interesting they say well you may have
acted with misconduct by uploading to
the livestream pre-recorded videos but
what you don't find is where's the
example of this actually happening if
this really was a rule that Facebook had
in its policies at some point in the
past and it was actually violated why
hide behind a secret actually James has
that that quote because I don't think we
filled the audience in and they did
respond yeah and they didn't deny that
they've been doing this I can read it to
you or you can throw it on screen but
I'm gonna read you Facebook's response
to this I action D booster so it's
interesting about the response bill is
that again within like an hour of our
story breaking Facebook corporate
responds to their buddies at the verge
calm and and all these mainstream uni
reporters are buddy-buddy with the
people inside Facebook Facebook says
quote some pages that tried to game the
system by uploading pre-recorded videos
to the live API a violation of
Facebook's policy if moderators found
the video the action D boost tag would
be applied to undo the newsfeed boost
otherwise applied to live videos and
Steven I asked you do you recall doing
this or did you no no no what no one
here has ever done a no quarterblack has
been in charge that no one here has ever
done it but if it would have been done
it would have been done a long time ago
wants to test because we thought there
was something fishy with our live
streams going on a second we're getting
1,000 viewers in a live stream here
we're getting twenty thirty thousand on
YouTube what's going on let's see if we
upload this as a video separately versus
a live feed if it would have been done
and I don't believe that it has I just
don't want to be put on the hook for
that it would have been done once to
test a theory that we thought Facebook
is doing exactly what they appeared to
be doing so no I don't know that we have
done it and we certainly been done it
consistently and their answer isn't very
to me it's not very clear if they just D
boost
that video that feed if they D boost the
whole page because we spent a lot of
money on Facebook advertising and a big
part of that was them courting us saying
hey the great thing here especially with
media is you're going to appear in
people's timelines we really want to be
a multimedia platform they came to us so
that's why it would be nice to have
clarification well another thing that
another fact that's very interesting is
that if you look at the code in the
video where it says Sigma distribution
Sigma is this is this name of this
program authored by this engineer Danny
Ben David with the intention of rooting
out like suicide I mean people on
Facebook livestream this is Facebook's a
big company people kill themselves on
face but there's pornography there's
people getting chopped in half if
there's all gory think child porn the
content review agents go through and and
go through that so this system was
apparently used to combat things like
that that does not exist in Facebook's
response but my insider showed me that
that the the reason why this was taken
allegedly was to combat suicidal or
violent things so I'm hearing two
different explanations of what this
Debus is for if you want my opinion as a
as someone who's done this for ten years
you know hidden camera exposing people I
think they're just caught and they're
not they're not debating what we've
exposed they're just sort of obfuscating
here and I think you guys are owed an
explanation I think you need to see the
back end and you need to know what's
going on with your live stream so in
their defense if it's the child porn
issue they could have seen your nudie
scene and been confused I just look like
a child bill is very baby like they
could have thought it was a cherubim
porn
you know the kind of the big thing is is
like I was saying is if there really was
a violation then they lead with saying
you have violated ex policy instead of a
post-hoc well okay our response now for
having done this for however many years
or months it's been going on and only to
your pages is because we think you may
have done something wrong but notice the
response does not even say the pages at
issues are the pages that were discussed
or steven crowder did these things they
don't say kind of generally oh well
that's why we did it and that might even
be true but I think James your point is
correct
there has to be an opening of the kimono
let's let's share what exactly I go to a
kimono reference of course he was trying
to course he's trying to make sure if
there ever were if there if there is to
be a lawsuit that he has the Asian card
in there but it's really only half a
kimono it's very short kimono
it's like Rob Lowe and thank you for
smoking I do have a question for you
though and then I thought maybe James
can also help clarify this how important
would it be if let's say an emotion for
is an emotion for discovery well you you
would serve discovery requests okay so
how important how important would it be
to let's say a case if it were verified
that this is a real thing and it seems
like it's a real thing they're not
denying it and then it was not equally
applied across conservative and liberal
platforms would that change it if they
would with if they said well this was
applied pretty much consistently cross
leftist platforms not just conservatives
it what it would do is it would only
mean that everyone is being conned
that's that's really what it would mean
it does make it worse if it's targeted
to a certain political group just as if
it would be bad if it was going after a
certain race or religion or that type of
thing but it's essentially saying a
political creed or race or religion is
bad but it's it's somewhat like hate
crimes the crime is still a crime
regardless of what whether it's a
hateful or targeted at a specific group
and and James can you confirm anything
like that that it was I know you said
your source mentioned this but do you
have any information that could confirm
that people on the right were more
unfairly targeted yes one of the there's
a part two of the story there's a D
boosting and then there's this other
part of the story of these documents on
my desk so I have my facts correct here
these are all these are all screenshots
taken by the woman who blew the whistle
this is something called a troll report
a troll report where they identify
language that there's a whole bunch of
tactics they use there's a glossary of
words that are used by individuals and
this guy confirms that they do in fact
demote bad content can you give us some
examples of those words because I read
this I've seen this and I was obviously
uh not appalled but I wish I could say
surprised not surprised just it was
really more of a disappointed apparently
huh you know that when Facebook so I
want to make sure you get my facts
straight I and and this is
incontrovertible proof Steven this is
not my words the whistleblower these are
documents obtained of this TRO report
where they use words like
lulz nor me mainstream media MSM that
the term MSM but this is these are terms
appropriated by conservatives liberals
don't really use the term MSM on social
media there's an sjw on their sjw's on
their what else what would know leftist
channel is it's not like they've
reappropriation der black single mom
with rickets maybe there's someone who
would carry that mantle but that's
something if they are saying these are
words to throttle pages putting in sjw
would definitely a disproportionately
target consumers lol is on that list so
know it's law ll ulz it's like a it's a
meme so this is after so here's the deal
the on the inside of Facebook we saw the
Seiji Yamamoto character one of the top
engineers right after the 2016 election
from Nintendo yeah me mean culturally
president Trump so they decided to have
an influence on elections and this is
one of the most powerful parts of the
story they assigned it what's called a a
troll score under the fake account index
a special feature leading this is a
direct quote leading up to important
elections unquote identifying these
keywords that conservatives use this is
like a big deal there and Mark
Zuckerberg said under oath in testimony
last spring that they don't do this that
they don't make political determinations
yes they ban Klansmen and pornography
and violence but they don't but this
engineer Seiji Yamamoto and he's not a
low-level guy he he's the head of the
whole department that heads this stuff
we have a copy of the of the
confidential report where they identify
these words and it's all in the
documentation that this whistleblower
gave to us I'd you have any more
questions you feel that for right now
okay that's James mr. O'Keefe please do
keep us in the loop obviously because we
do have a half agent crack in here who
crack and crack Maracana keeps I don't
know why I keep saying it incorrectly it
is a project very tusk calm slash brave
not to be confused with it awful Pixar
film wasn't leaked swing and a Miss for
Pixar with the redhead James thank you
for being here brother we appreciate it
thanks Steve and no no no you don't need
a break we know you'll break we're gonna
be going with seven plus one here and
just
oh I think oh yeah okay home by the way
there is no written one in the chamber
we check out this ruler just tuning in
now we checked and cleared it this week
is actually if you haven't noticed a
thing seven plus one big tech legal
dramas ah yeah we're looking at well
speaking speaking of which I had a quick
question for a half asian law you were
both muted during the James O'Keefe
interview in case you well that I've
just sitting here listening and soaking
it all in there has there been any
widespread throttling and Andy boosting
essentially of liberal accounts like
have have a lot of liberals come forward
because all I've really heard and this
may be my own bias he just said that
while you're in the bathroom no you just
said no as far as you know as far as he
knows because the trigger words they use
like any page it has s JW yes if you
haven't seen in the media I have I
thought I knew the answer I think the
answer would be no but I'm asking him
like is there anything behind the scenes
were like oh it's both conservatives and
liberals getting screwed it just seems
like conservatives are getting screwed
and I just wanted it to be not my
opinion but fact hold on you don't know
yet that's why you have to sue allegedly
allegedly according to the eyewitness
[Laughter]
documents that we have own photo of a
computer screen allegedly it is that the
specific code was only seen on
conservative pages and of those
conservative pages the ones that were
memorable Mike servo [ __ ] got an
actual screenshot she was not able to
get a screenshot of Stephens but
affirmative Lee said I saw the code on
Stephens page and then said it was not
tonight I've seen other pages that did
not have the code right so is it
possible that it is on other pages
absolutely is that something that
Facebook come out of be like a guys
actually it's on everyone hey look we
can show you the usage that we actually
only did it if you uploaded a
pre-recorded video to the live feed
which is the excuse they've given right
but they have not said any no they
haven't any of that nominated rule which
which we may or may not have violated
once I'm willing to bet my bottom dollar
that we have never done that and if we
did you don't get the throttle an entire
page something else I was gonna say this
is one thing to the why and I really did
enjoy Alex Jones on Joe Rogan show and
they're both actually both been on the
show I can still entertain both friends
great Tom but there was a point when
they were talking they're saying is it
true
that on face on YouTube now they do you
monetize any videos that have the word
truth or Liberty in them and I guess it
is and here's the thing it's not so it's
the lie is not necessary because the
truth is bad enough we have videos up
there like the truth about guns the
truth about we have multiple videos have
the words and not all of them have been
D monetized right so is it true that
conservative videos have been unfairly
targeted absolutely have we seen a
disproportionate amount of demonization
yes but you don't need to lie and say
hey I heard any video that even has
truth in the title is D monetizing it's
not accurate and it doesn't help the
legal cases going forward this is
something you nursed and there's
bitching on social media and then
there's actually taking legal matters
into your own hands and taking the
proper steps and using the avenues that
are available to you so just my only
point is if you don't know don't lie
because then you toss allies in with all
the truth alright but these are the
seven plus one big tech legal dramas uh
which really shouldn't be so brutal they
were missed it's almost like Big Tex run
about out of ideas at the DMZ sense
parties number seven to copyright a
Mockingbird yeah that's that's not good
you should attorneys six this is no
surprise your might your favorite my
cousin Dorsey yeah that's number six
I want to hear Penn tell us read one let
me give us a number five number five is
a few good men hating Facebook engineers
Photoshop team and I've seen Stephen
Colbert's photo shops and Bill Maher
since they're just absolutely terrible
we really have great people even Brendan
I'll say this one because I'm already
guilty of the eight speech number four
and justice for all [ __ ] makeup
tutorials can you do number three can
you read it absolutely anatomy of a
[ __ ] claim it's not a very iconic
poster that now number two inherit the
windbags yeah those are no no that was
that was the
monkey the actual monkey trial people
are you know people it was the
evolutionary trial no one talks about
how back then just a lot of the
evolutionary theory was incredibly
racist they just gloss over accuse
they'll talk about conservative
Christians a big we can even want you to
say number two their pen tell us all
right number two an uncivil half-asian
yes an uncivil happy by the way we have
a major conspiracy episode coming up and
it is about the graphic designer for all
early 90s through early 2000 John
Travolta series of all the films I'm
pretty sure it was the same person
I'm not saying Illuminati but number two
can't forget number two legally
half-asian yeah that's not so much a
drama used I don't know if I should be
concerned that my legal representation
is as amused as the part-time Montreal
good tastes in humor number one top big
tech legal dramas is presumed guilty and
the plus one this week plus one top ten
top seven top seven plus 1/2 plus 1/2
plus one I can send the best one the
plus 1/2 plus one top big legal dramas
seven plus one did you hear it twice it
just laid itself again oh yeah this is
this is this the show I think this is
why the TriCaster do have a track a sore
thumb Canson like 16 bullets you're also
very bad wait yeah 16 you're right
that's right seven plus one I was
thinking six plus one another thing in
the week a the ppk/s is seven plus one
yeah
Thank You snow I wasn't really on the
map again illegal crap all week we're
going to keep you up so if we were to
let's say file a suit would we be able
to let people viewing right now no by
sometime next week yeah we would
definitely well I mean look there's a
there's a lot of work that we put in not
just on a legal team but working with
you and your team to make sure that
everything that we're doing we're
verifying it we're checking against
legal structure we're looking about what
the the National consequences are and
also weighing it against the fact that
it's going to take time away from
content and away from the audience so
that's why we have to go out do the
right thing both to the audience and
from a legal standpoint also being that
you know this isn't just about you it's
it's about you and everyone else I mean
there have been times where both the
left and the right have stood up and
said what are these social media
companies doing with the shadow banning
and their ridiculous rules and the
subjective application of them here
again though consistently consistently
consistently this only one name between
Gizmodo and James O'Keefe investigation
is steven crowder and and so it gives us
more of a leg to stand on so that we can
hopefully pave the way for the rest of
you because I don't want to do this the
rest of my life and I'm hoping for
someone else to come I want to see other
conservative channels out there I want
to see more I want to see you guys grow
and to do that listen it's a multi
tiered approach join up at the Ed Mudd
Club you help us fight this battle you
help us have not only bill Richman but
hopefully I don't know clerks or the
clerk's yeah
your associate I said the associate the
clerk I shut the clerk and a legal team
and listen let me know if here's one
thing a lot of you go sue Charles Hermes
ooh Twitter so well it's at some point
that does mean that there are going to
be some days some weeks if we're in
court or I have to take the stand or
you're gonna miss out in the show and
and that's a part of what mug club is
and I want to make sure that if we go
down this road that you understand the
magnitude of it they do understand the
severity of it that you understand we
are doing it for you and so I want to
know if if you're willing to sacrifice
some content in the short term for us to
be free from the shackles of corporate
censorship long term half-asian lawyer
bill Richman I look forward to the
updates thank you very much pent Ellis
calm buddy go subscribe to him on
YouTube he's one of the funniest men I
know in a break and we'll be right back
what's closed
[Music]
hey mud club members there's a lot of
crime going on in Mexico and the drug
cartels are sort of infiltrating the
suburbs and ms-13 is all over Long
Island you know with oxycontin if you
want to help just stick with the calling
the police and stuff like that I don't
recommend actually getting involved in
sort of you know citizens arrests and
it's sort of like what are you guys
doing there and I'm gonna tell the gobs
in that that doesn't turn out great
it's a heartbreaking sight a cold hungry
path Asian lawyer with no one to suit
for only 27 cents and any you can ensure
steady nutritious diet of big tech
shadow banners and corporate hypocrites
to a hungry half asian lawyer feed half
asian lawyer bill Richmond join mugs
today
[Music]
hello another with color viewers hopper
here don't forget the new condition to
the podcast on the go on iTunes or
SoundCloud on the audio you can download
it you can listen it yeah I want to be
clear here that I wasn't joking like
there's people you don't like
Oh Trump's a Nazi and I hate these proud
boys and these Patriots yell at them
sure do that but then when their actual
gangsters or actual criminals maybe take
a step back yeah
let them sort of mind their own business
and you should probably mind yours tell
my wife and that picture wasn't me
[Music]
[Music]
no that was someone who's drowning
trying to do a lot flare pose but then
gets taken away by the current
but he's so narcissistic that he still
keeps going I got a squeeze
I gotta flex better than flare all kinds
of all kinds of conservatives twins by
the way oh yeah yeah they're just cream
they've gone full bore so far thank you
so much I didn't lawyer bill Richmond we
will keep you updated and let us know
which sins you think are most egregious
your wit has nothing with the power of
the mob we've just we found four motions
for information before in the past we've
tried to play nicely we've settled out
of court it's gotten to the point where
it's really impede her ability to make
laveyan thank you so much to Penn telus
comedy please go subscribe to his
YouTube channel he does a podcast with
Mike Ward by the way yes he did come you
network so something I do want to talk
about this before but I think it's more
relevant than ever is this mantra that I
hear a lot and I think it's incredibly
use word toxic now these terms have been
co-opted but it really is toxic the idea
that failure is not an option here that
a lot failure is not an option well
right now this is an example we're
talking about this we're fighting
Facebook Disney ABC the Academy I don't
even know if they are Disney ABC
internal battles of course we have
battles well-known battles with YouTube
this has been going on for a long time
and it is I want to say sometimes it
feels insurmountable and I'll come back
to this sometimes of course I want to
pack up and go home
it has been a very very trying week and
using only no Hopper's been sick he's
been doing very well thank you so much
for your comments I'm not at the top of
my health game right now but let me just
tell you something
failure is absolutely an option I know
that I've talked about this a lot but
I'd like to put a finer point on it
a good example recently I was watching
television and I saw a commercial that
mentioned a Huntsville Alabama you know
rocket City USA and the man in the
commercial was talking about how failure
failure was not an option now here's the
thing I understand where he's coming
from I'm not saying that rocket
scientists NASA whoever this guy was is
being dishonest he's effectively trying
to express the importance of the task
and the severity of the failure therein
okay someone could die something could
blow up
I appreciate the accountability being
expressed in the sentiment so do not get
mad don't say you're attacking NASA
that's not what I'm doing here but I
disagree with the phrase and I
it's one we need to do away with I
certainly would encourage you to do away
with it in your personal life mainly
because I see so many people use it as a
personal mantra failure is not an option
failures not an option failure is not an
option
kind of like and I think I can I think I
can I think I can but I've talked about
this before my good friend shale has
talked about this before failure is
always an option in fact it's often the
easiest and most readily available
option that doesn't mean that the
consequences are easier desirable but
the action of failing is always there
every step of the way it's more apparent
to me now than ever as we talked about
on this show your guiding light above
all else I hate this sounds cheesy but
it needs to be truth and so I don't
think that ever denying reality is the
most productive route I just don't
believe it I know that it's been helpful
for me and I think would behoove many of
you to consider dropping the mindset for
a more accurate one failure is always an
option don't tell yourself it's not if
you tell yourself it's not you're
effectively denying this huge this
ribbon this milky way this this cosmic
belt of reality sometimes it's the
biggest cosmic belt of reality in your
path certainly the most looming let me
give you an example let's say you're
driving down a freeway there's a major
roadblock let's say a five car pileup
does it help you to say there's no
pileup it's not even on the table or is
it more productive to see the pileup to
acknowledge it and to refuse to allow it
to impede your progress see the former
mindset that of telling yourself that
there is no roadblock failure is not an
option it leads to what what does it
lead to riding straight into that
roadblock the ladder acknowledging it
seeing the roadblock including this data
incorporating the information into your
reality largely because it is reality
I'll come back to that in a second
living your truth will be more
productive it would lead to a solution
you know it's there but you don't want
to end up in that roadblock so you're
more likely to take a different route to
recalibrate to succeed why do we tell
ourselves this that failure is not an
option why do we consistently lie to
ourselves and why is it been accepted as
though it's yeah I see it in the
Christian community as well as this sort
of self-help guru community which is
more productive okay let's just look at
this from a pragmatic point of view the
failure is not an option mantra or let's
just say let's we switched it to fail
is dis allowable I'd like to see more
people saying failure is dis allowable
as opposed to lying themselves saying
that failures not an option it may sound
trivial but one is a soundbite in one is
a way of life one it's a mantra okay
that sounds good on daytime talk shows
it sells self-help books the others are
very non sexy but necessary mindset to
deal with your own shortcomings most
importantly one is dishonest and one is
truthful
I'd say it's honestly it's even more
severe then than that and that one is
dishonest and arguably the most
destructive way possible and then it's
the kind of dishonesty in which you lie
to yourself but when your marriage
failures not an option failures not an
option in your work failures and an
option failures not an option in your
physical training failures not an option
failures not an option only to find
yourself at some point when you've been
living with this mantra I don't know
it's a broken marriage possibly a
divorce losing your job or in the most
literal sense physical harm finding
yourself under a barbell by the way I
don't know what's happened with my wrist
it's not the power glove with what the
boy from Boy Meets World the brother the
old Fred says huge wizard is it so bad
by the way that's why I believe that
physical training is so important a lot
of people say oh you're a meathead no
sometimes experience in the most literal
strain possible tells you a lot about
yourself a lot about your place in this
world and how you interact with it so do
me a favor we do this every week and
often you you tweet me or you send me
messages and it ends up on the mug club
life advice segment do me a favor run
this experiment find out what your
maximal strength is how much you can
squat deadlift how high I don't care how
many pull-ups you can do okay this is
just an experiment I'm not saying that
how many pull-ups you can do determines
your marital quality but just find
something that measures your maximal
strength write it down okay perform at
once now I want you to add 15% doesn't
seem like a ton right tell yourself
failure is not an option
repeat as many times as necessary listen
your eat listen your amp up music get
Slayer going I don't know what you
listen to nowadays I don't know if
Linkin Park is still a thing that's it
pissed me off in high school get
yourself to peak by any means possible
and try it pause this right now try it
add 15% did you succeed see that's why
the mantra of failure is not an option
is so harmful because it's all of us
lying to yourself all the while these
roadblocks keep piling up you will come
to that roadblock you will come to that
pileup it's there it's always there but
if you acknowledge it if you're honest
with yourself you can prepare for it and
you can choose not always but often to
disallow failure so I want you to take
that same experiment okay find out your
maximal strength same as before it could
be a squad could be even a number of
pull-ups it just has to be consistent
with what you did before okay now
instead of performing it and then adding
15 percent of amping yourself up with
failures not an option I want you to
take a different tack I want you to
acknowledge that that is your limitation
that going past it will lead to failure
keep that in the back of your mind okay
but don't reach it don't max out and
here's what I want you to do I want you
to not perform to failure but to chart a
course to improve it for example let's
say your max maximum squat is 300 pounds
consistently do let's call it 275 pounds
but gradually add every time you go to
the gym 5 pounds
work hard work hard work diligently but
not to failure if you can do 15 pull-ups
only do 12 or 13 but consistently and
add one rep write it down and then I
want you to come back and note when you
surpass your previous limits I guarantee
you this is a promise okay not an empty
promise I guarantee you that using that
method you will surpass it and you'll
probably be surprised by how quickly it
happens now this experiment here it's
not about lifting weights it's to show
you that one way of doing things the
failure is not an option doesn't work
you can try and move that weight shove
and even strain all you want you will be
no closer
0% closer to achieving growth than you
were when you started the other while
not sexy very workman like it's not a
show horse it's a Clydesdale will lead
to break through the break that you were
seeking in the first place it's a great
irony in life that these triumphant
these grandiose ways that we try to
achieve our breakthroughs they're
usually the ones that keep us from
achieving them because it's the
preparation that matters it's the
in-betweens like I've talked but it's
the unsexy measures we take when no one
is watching when the excitements worn
off and failure is always an option in
the back of our mind see one the failure
is not an option is effectively the
false mantra of
living your truth that's why I think I
hate it so much where is the decision to
acknowledge failure as an option but
disallowing it to determine your
long-term circumstances is the
equivalent to living in the truth I
don't think there's anything sillier
than saying this I'm speaking my truth
that's a hedge to say you could be a
liar that's what you could be saying
sorry corner black Garrett has to hit
the sensor button a little pissed off
this week I don't really care if let it
fly out I'll reset I'll recalibrate next
week because I realized failure with my
vocabulary is an option but what is
living your truth me if you're not
living in the truth there is absolute
truth and sometimes your truth and the
truth are incongruent as a matter of
fact I'd wager more often than not
because often the truth is really
uncomfortable but guess what the truth
is always there it's always there and if
your truth isn't the truth it's gonna
hit you like a brick in the face maybe
not today maybe not tomorrow sooner or
later the truth is coming from you I say
from you or for you I don't care this
bumper sticker show like they were
climbing on a summit hell does that mean
what does it mean the truth is you have
limits Rock no you're a human and you're
breakable we all are where people live
themselves on their sick how many times
you know these people are positive
speaking Booker I understand you don't
want to be a negative Nancy but you're
not sick and they cough up a lung listen
you can't lift that weight at some point
in your life you're going to die you are
sick your marriage has problems you're
dropping the ball at certain aspects of
your job or as a father as a husband
you've made promises to yourself that
you haven't kept that's reality and to
tell yourself that failure is not an
option is to consistently live in a
state of denying reality it's delusional
by definition right now to give you an
idea to tie this back into us and I
don't want this to just be about me we
were hit with four copyright claims in
the same day on the same show to try and
suppress it three have been defeated
they're just biding their time on the
fourth hoping that the Oscars will no
longer be relevant and that you don't
watch it when it's available please
prove them wrong we're currently
preparing
for an epic legal war with Facebook one
that will test the integrity and
fortitude not only myself but everyone
this team also you how long will you
stick it out how long will you support
us this week we had to miss three shows
to fight these battles believe me that
wasn't fun for us there are going to be
a few more weeks like that if this goes
to court how long are you in when the
dust has settled the excitement of the
initial war the battle cry has died out
when we're in the trenches rained on
covered in dirt waiting are you still
there because failure is always an
option I have to be honest with myself
right now
failure is the most easy readily
available option I'm not a rock I'm not
a man without limits I'm a very limited
man who is fallible and breakable it'll
be a lot easier to fail right now
because rather than continuing rather
than reinvesting and creating for the
unheard majority of Americans you the
international fans out there know I have
a lot of Canadian Greek Orthodox fan
tell us just told me this I could
collect my marbles that I've gained thus
far right now and go home even more I'm
at a point right now where I know that
the failure of this program of this
movement of your movement right now is a
much more easy option today than it will
be once we're in this [ __ ] because
once we're in this fight we can't unring
that Bell unless we win I can't recoup
all the resources finances creative
energy and just life energy that's been
invested into it failure is a much more
easy option for me to choose today then
it would be tomorrow or the next day or
the next and I know that and I struggle
with it I'm not gonna lie to you I
struggle with it all the time there are
times where I come really close to
calling it and packing it in didn't I
that's a lot of myself and to lie to you
about it for the sake of an inner some
kind of inspirational soundbite would
not only be dishonest
it would cloud my judgement to the
decisions that I have to make for all of
us moving forward it would also be
little by the way the magnitude of what
you've done for me you the listeners
view for us the truth is that you've
helped us build something so impactful
so important to such a multitude of
people that the walls are closing in
tempting us by providing the option of
failure that's where we are right now
failure is a would be a relief failure
is an option I'm not gonna lie to you I
go step further and say not only an
option
a very possible outcome that's why it's
at the front of my mind I want it to be
at the front of yours because then we're
all in the same page knowing that right
now at this moment in history we all
have a decision to make we can choose
failure right now we can choose easy
right now and it's available it's right
there we can choose relief we can choose
peace through failure right now or we
can choose to go through the hard door
and this may not be as inspirational it
may not sell as many books but I can
promise you this so long as you all of
you watching listening streaming choose
to go through those hard doorways those
thresholds meaning many doorway after
doorway after doorway so long as you
keep choosing to do that with us I
promise you so will I you tell me un
comment let me know
[Music]
Puran I am - the rest of you fill your
hand you son of a for everyone else
there's mud flow see you next week
hopefully more show
[Music]